موسكو اي مسؤول بريطاني يمكن
اعتباره هدفا مشروعا والجيش
الروسي يقتنص صيدا ثمينا في
اوكرانيا وبين المانيا وروسيا
اندلعت المواجهة مجددا. وكييب
وحلفائها يخططون لقمة سلام لكن
دون موسكو فكيف ذلك? والناتو
يتدخل عسكريا في البلقان بانتظار
الرد الروسي. هل يخطط مؤسس فاغنر
للانقلاب على بريجوجن يفاجئ
العالم. هدية عسكرية ثمينة من
النرويج لاوكرانيا وكوريا
الشمالية تعلن فشلها للمرة
الاولى وتايوان تتحضر بسلاح يسبب
الصداع لبكين. والجزائر تتلقى
طلبا فلسطينيا وترد لن نتخلى
عنكم. والجيش السوداني يتنصل عن
الهدنة فور سريانها. روسيا تلتهم
صيدا اوكرانيا عندما لا تتجه
الحرب لوضع اوزارها يتجه
المتحاربون الى السلام وهو اقل
الحلول خسارة وهنا هي كييف تسلك
طريق السلام لكن بطريقة غريبة
وعجيبة حيث يريد الاوكرانيون
سلاما من طرف واحد. ايعقل ذلك?
اذ قالت وولستريت جورنال نقلا عن
مستشار رئاسي اوكراني رفيع
ودبلوماسيين اوروبيين ان
اوكرانيا وحلفاء يخططون لعقد قمة
لزعماء العالم من شأنها استبعاد
روسيا بهدف حشد الدعم لشروط كييب
لانهاء الحرب. ووفق الصحيفة فان
خطة القمة تحظى بدعم قوي من
القادة الاوروبيين. وان فرنسا
والدنمارك والسويد عرضنا
استضافتها. لكن ان لم تكن روسيا
ضمن هذه القمة فعن اي سلام
يتحدثون وكيف سينهون الحرب مع
موسكو وهي مستبعدة من هذا
الحوار. اترك الاجابة لكم. لنعد
الى موضوعنا. حيث تستمر المعارك
بالتصاعد في اوكرانيا ليقتنص
الجيش الروسي صيدا اوكرانيا
ثمينا وذلك باعلان الدفاع الروسي
عن تدمير اخر سفينة حربية تابعة
للقوات البحرية الاوكرانية يوري
اوليفرينكو في ميناء اودريسا يوم
التاسع والعشرين من مايو لتواصل
موسكو عملية صيدها. وهنا اعلن
وزير الدفاع الروسي سيرجي شويغان
الروسية تمكنت للمرة الثانية من
تدمير منظومة باتريوت اخرى
للدفاع الجوي في العاصمة
الاوكرانية كييف. ومن الغريب
ايضا ان منظومة باتريوت التي
زودت بها واشنطن كييف لتدافع عن
نفسها ضد طائرات موسكو اصبحت
كييف بحاجة لمن يدافع عنها من
صواريخ الباتريوت هذه. حيث تناقل
رواد مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
لحظة سقوط صاروخ من منظومة
باتريك للصواريخ المضادة
الامريكية الصنع على طريق سريع
مزدحم في كييف اثناء تفعيلها في
ارجاء العاصمة. ليصبح حال
الاوكران كما يقول العرب
المستجير بعمر عند كربته
كالمستجير من الرمضاء بالنار. من
جانبه حاكم اقليم كراسنودر
الروسي بنيامين كاندراتينكو كان
قد اعلن ان حريقا نشب في مصفاة
ابيبسكي لتكرير النفط في الاقليم
نتيجة هجوم بمسيرة اوكرانية
ليخرج المتحدث باسم مجلس الوزراء
الالماني ستيفن نيبشتريت مصرحا
بان برلين تعتبر ضربات القوات
المسلحة الاوكرانية ضد اهداف في
روسيا باسلحة اوكرانية الصنع
مشروعة من وجهة نظر القانون
الدولي. الا ترون ان التصريح
الالماني متهور بعض الشيء. نعم
يبدو ذلك وهذا ما قاله الكريملين
لكن برلين واصلت صب الزيت على
النار دون وهنا كانت العاصمة
الالمانية قد اعلنت اغلاق اربع
من اصل خمس قنصليات روسية في
البلاد ردا على ما اسمته اجراءات
موسكو. وكانت الخارجية الروسية
قد اعلنت في وقت سابق عن فرض
قيود على الحد الاقصى لعدد افراد
البعثة الدبلوماسية الالمانية.
وذلك ايضا كان ردا على قرار
الجانب الالماني مغادرة وطرد
العشرات من الموظفين
والدبلوماسيين الروس. في لتتجه
بوصلة موسكو نحو خصم اوروبي اخر
لا يقل عداوة عن المانيا وبعد ان
كان وزير الخارجية البريطاني
جيمس كليفيلي قد صرح بان
اوكرانيا لها الحق في استخدام
القوة خارج حدودها جاء الرد
الروسي على لسان نائب رئيس مجلس
الامن الروسي دميتري ميدفيديف
بقوله ان اي مسؤول بريطاني يمكن
اعتباره هدفا مشروعا بالنظر الى
ان بريطانيا في حالة حرب مع
روسيا الاتحادية. بينما صار
الرئيس البولندي عكس التيار هذه
المرة ليدلي بتصريح غير متوقع عن
نجاحات بوتين. ويقول اليوم
يقولون ان فلاديمير بوتين خسر
الحرب وهزيمته هي ان فنلندا
انضمت الى الناتو على الرغم من
ان الشعب الفنلندي يتردد لسنوات
عديدة فيما اذا كان سيتخلى عن
الحياد. سيداتي وسادتي فلاديمير
بوتين لم يخسر حربا واحدة. ومن
اوروبا نعود الى روسيا وبعد ان
سئل طباخ بوتين هل يخطط للانقلاب
على بوتين اجاب وقال ان جيشه ليس
كبيرا بما يكفي لبدء عملية تمرد
وانقلاب. مؤكدا ان مجموعته تتمتع
بعلاقة جيدة مع الرئيس الروسي
وفق ما نقله موقع انساير
البريطاني. والمح بريغوشن بدلا
من ذلك الى ان وزير الروسي سيرجي
شوقا يمكن ان ينظم انقلابا لانه
يمكنه الوصول الى القوات الخاصة
الروسية. وفي سياق اخر قالت
وزيرة الخارجية النرويجية ان
بلادها ستقدم لاوكرانيا برنامج
مساعدة عسكرية مدته خمس سنوات
يبلغ اجماليه حوالي سبعة مليارات
يورو. وهنا نبتعد قليلا عن روسيا
نحو حليفتها صربيا. وبعد اشتعال
التوترات بين اعلن حلف الناتو
ارسال قوات العمليات الاحتياطية
لغرب البلقان الى لمواجهة
الاضطرابات الاخيرة في شمال
الاقليم. كما اعطى النيتو
تعليماته بتقليص فترة الجاهزية
اللازمة لتحريك المزيد من تلك
القوات. ليأتي الرد من موسكو
محذرة الناتو بان عليه الا يستفز
صربيا. الاحداث والتطورات. تسلم
الرئيس الجزائري عبدالمجيد تبون
رسالة مهمة من رئيس دولة فلسطين
محمود عباس. وهناك وجه الرئيس
الجزائري رسالة للشعب الفلسطيني
مؤكدا فيها ان الجزائر لن تتخلى
عنهم. قالت تقارير غربية انه
تحسبا لاشتعال حرب في بحر الصين
الجنوبي تواصل تايوان تكثيف
صناعة الطائرات المسيرة بجانب
استيراد مسيرة وتكنولوجيا متقدمة
من حليفتها واشنطن وهو سلاح يسبب
صداعا برأس لانه وبحسب التقارير
قد يساعد بكسر اي حصار ترغب بكين
لفرضه هناك. وبعد سلسلة طويلة من
التجارب الصاروخية الناجحة ها هي
بيونج يانج تعلن ان صاروخا
فضائيا يحمل قمرا صناعيا
للاستطلاع العسكري تحطم في البحر
بعد اطلاقه بسبب خلل فني بحسب ما
افادت وكالة الانباء المركزية
الكورية الشمالية. قررت القيادة
العامة للقوات السودانية تعليق
المحادثات الجارية في جدة بسبب
ما اعتبرته عدم التزام قوات
الدعم السريع بتنفيذ البنود التي
نص عليها الاتفاق وخرق الهدنة.